time magazine predicting a gloomy
forecast for president biden on their
new cover which commemorates the
president's first year along with the
dark cloud hanging over his
administration joe koncha is here in joe
the time magazine headline how the biden
administration lost its way quote an
administration that pledged to restore
competence and normalcy seems
overmatched and reactive democrats fear
that a harsh political backlash looms
sounds about right to me what say you
you have to wonder uh carly what white
house press secretary jensachi and chief
of staff ron clayne are thinking right
now because i am certain they didn't
have media turns against us on its bingo
card one year ago and look it's clear
and here's your captain obvious
statement coming there ain't nothing
going right for biden harris right now
and unlike bill clinton in his first
year when he was polling at 37 percent
or barack obama who was at 40 heading
into an election year you don't get the
feeling there's a comeback coming for
this administration because the public
more and more sees this president this
vice president the administration as a
whole as incompetent over their head out
of touch with the pulse of the american
people their priorities right now are
inflation crime covid education and the
border that's top of mind right now in
terms of the public's priorities so what
does team biden do they push a massive
spending bill and and what they call
voting rights plus the the president is
acting his age at this point he's
stubborn he's unsteady and the vice
president has no plan b just go watch
her interviews recently 2021 was bad
2022 may actually be worse for this
administration democrats who are
accomplished at complaining but patently
poor it seems at governing and executing
these days
joe that was the best summary that we've
heard on this you literally hit
everything perfectly clip that air it
throughout the network for the rest of
the day meantime liberal media keeping
brianna cut for story off their home
pages we've got to get serious here and
when they did run it they didn't use the
suspect's picture made no mention of his
enormous rap sheet joe forget as
journalists but as humans how can they
callously ignore that part of the story
all in furtherance of this perverse woke
agenda
todd it's a replay of the the waukesha
christmas parade right
here's the story line the suspect with a
rap sheet stretching a country mile who
had no business being on the street
senselessly murdering a young woman with
her whole life ahead of her waukesha
obviously it was more than just one
person it was grandmothers and it was
children and imagine if someone wearing
a make america great again hat had
committed those murders in wisconsin or
this horrific murder in california it
would be wall to wall to wall coverage
but it seems if the suspect doesn't
match up with a certain political
narrative the story is forgotten quickly
and and that's just journalistic
injustice quite frankly
no and we're not going to forget it here
joe thank you so much for joining us
this morning on these two very important
topics happy friday hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now